have you been on Mark Wahlberg's social
media recently no
then another thing I kind of wanted to
explore with you because
he has a very bizarre presence I know
he's very a drip or drowned he's very
dripped out in Municipal so there's no
he doesn't add a lot of context he just
will start the video and he's like
already mid thought
pink taco
Fletcher all that beautiful oh my God
there's some chicken and some kind of
asada amazing
[Laughter]
yeah yeah okay go back no
go up go to the uh
go to the shirtless one of him right
there
and go to the other shirtless one
it was in the box
out of here game changer
look at that
is that his brand yeah it's the whack
his clothes
it's so funny is that Tiffany what is
that Tiffany blue cold plunge challenge
this is watch out Jojo
this thing is as cold as I've never felt
the entire life is like going into the
Atlantic
come here babe
why do okay oh that's it that's it okay
what is what the [__] is the point of
that JoJo better watch out dude nice
smart nice Mario get in there
JoJo better watch out
cold as I've ever felt it's like getting
into the Atlantic or the Pacific
he looked at his wife shut the [__] up
shut the [__] up
what are you doing you're ruining my
video such a [__] mouth
I love there's no conclusion he doesn't
there's no yeah like okay I know this is
a real stretch but I feel when I watch
these
as though I'm watching like
like a like a
like a 19 year old
like junkie or something like
like that [__] pink taco
pink tie you gotta hatties man I just
had some carne asada oh
yes get a picture
and he just walks it's like some you
know what I mean like some drunk young
person outside of like a shitty Club in
[__] Connecticut
it's like a dude you kind of know yeah
like oh Mark is like yo
the pink taco
yo Mario cold plunge the coolest plunge
I ever plunged
sick cold bro
like the like the Antarctic
is that what he said I don't know he
slides in there or the Pacific shut up
[__]
[Laughter]
laughs
I was like what did you do you just
wanted to join you just want to have fun
but also this is like clearly a thirst
trap yeah yeah so weird for your for
your do you just hand the camera to your
wife and be like yo film this film this
for other chicks
Vegas baby Vegas baby Cathedral Arya
let's go
what it what is it what's going on
give some context
oh dude it's Fletcher Azul let's go what
are they doing an event it's at the Aria
man let's go hey let's go you should
know that just let's go I like that his
profile picture is not good yeah there's
something that feels really scammy about
his whole apparatus yeah I mean
that's it's just like overly overly
branded even if it's your own [__] it's
like of every single video
is it's got to be at least a little bit
genuine all right what if I've launches
Wahlberg week offering seven new classes
designed by Mark Wahlberg and Gunner
Peterson in participating Studios
worldwide I'm sorry man I do think there
is something a little embarrassing
um
I understand if you already go to f45
and then you're like that's this wall oh
fine yeah yeah but if you're you never
worked out before and then you see
there's Wahlberg week and you're like
it's mush this is my time I think I
might have to pull up so I'm a little
corny about that decked out in Municipal
yeah hey yo we're gonna have some Casa
whatever after this right
yeah it's a guy we're about we're all
meeting up at Pink Taco after Wahlberg
week bro some guy in a like head to toe
Municipal yeah takes a selfie tags Mark
yeah like yo Wahlberg week it might be
useful gear shout out Mark and he just
he actually like responds to the guy's
story he's like yo don't tag me if
you're a dude
don't attack me if you're a dude
or he or Mark just gets on his story
he's like
yo Municipal the brand [__] with it
listen if you're a dude don't [__]
tag me
I don't [__] swing that way
ladies let me know what you rocking
today all right 4am let's go 4am off the
charts municipal
sahit
[__] with it
I love the I love it's like the freight
the random phrases
that's crazy man that's all of this
stress like he's ready to complain holy
[__] it's pretty what
ready to complain why is his profile
like 2010 no this is the municipal one
right dude this this feels like the like
the swag era like the jerking era 100
I'm fully waiting for a video to just be
like some kids jerking well hold on
all right it's a dance it's a dance it's
a dance that [__] in the middle that
sport utility
anorak yeah
horrendous
this feels like the swag era it feels my
Spacey yeah that's what it is everything
about him fills Myspace it's the it's
the vagueness in the way he speaks
I feel like that was old social media
yeah like dudes like flexing pictures
and like the captions are mad vague if
you ain't up and getting it then you
just getting got yeah like
the [__] the [__] is Mark talking about
I was putting some [__] on his
pictures
yeah social media now is like the
Antarctic yeah yeah
cold like the Antarctic swimming with
the shock sweat Jimmy municipal.com
[Laughter]
social media now is like
so I just had a colonoscopy yeah or no
it's just like what's up guys just did a
coffee enema honestly not that bad yeah
yeah yeah
uh come with me to take a [__] at
Elefante yeah Santa Monica yeah yeah
yeah I appreciate that girl that [__] is
hilarious hilarious but that's what it
is yeah it's that and like absurdist
sketches yeah yeah I'm glad we just
promoted all of his brands for free for
30 minutes
I'm craving a burger
exactly I would like to kind of work out
like him I would like to work out his
body is pretty sick you know what I
can't wait for man
yo you guys are [__] condescending
just because Mark's trying to put out a
program in the world that enables people
to better themselves doesn't mean you
have to [__] on it you don't have to
like it
but let people do what they want to do
yeah
nah nah
I'm standing by Wahlberg week is a
little corny
it's a little cheesy